Vado mentioned that we should provide
bitmaps at different resolutions in our
app the 48 dip icon on the nexus s looks
to be about the same size as on the
nexus 4 and on the nexus 5 however in
reality this asset that's being
displayed is actually a lot bigger in
terms of pixels compared to this one to
confirm we can check out the app
resource folders in the drawable folders
we see that our app has a 48 by 48 pixel
elantra icon for mdpi devices located in
the drawable mdpi folder to make an
equivalent icon for the higher density
devices we need to make that icon
progressively larger to know exactly how
big to make these images and what the
dipped pixel conversion should be we use
an mdpi device as the baseline this is
where one dip equals one pixel then on
the hdpi device one dip equals 1.5
pixels and then it increases from there
all the way to an xxhdpi device where
one dip equals four pixels for more info
on the conversions see the link below
following those rules these are the
sizes of the launcher icon in our
drawable folders the mdpi one is 48
pixels by 48 pixels the one for hdpi is
1.5 times the size of this one for an
xhdpi device the icon is 2 times the
size of the mdpi one and for an xxhdpi
device the icon is three times the size
of this one